[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports nous devons instaurer aux
êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
les premiers pas de jean castex en tant
que premier ministre aux français une
visite dans une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire dans l'essonne la relance
de l'économie et la priorité affichée
par le nouveau chef du gouvernement
alors que plusieurs entreprises
prévoient des plans de licenciement un
déplacement à l'issue d'un entretien
avec emmanuel macron à l'elysée ce matin
en vue de former un nouveau gouvernement
les décisions les discussions qui ont
repris ce soir avec le chef de l'état
[Musique]
une femme de gauche pour la première
fois à la tête de la ville de marseille
michel ribeiro la succède à jean claude
gaudin à l'issue d'un premier conseil
municipal à rebondissements la candidate
gauche et des écologistes a obtenu la
majorité absolue grâce au soutien de
dernière minute de l'ancien socialiste
au siam samia ghali
les élus du rassemblement national et
ont quitté la séance
ils dénoncent les petits arrangements au
détriment d'un vrai débat pour les
marseillais
et puis la fête nationale de
l'indépendance aux états unis est
maintenu malgré la crise sanitaire alors
que le pays reste le plus touché au
monde la maison blanche maintient les
festivités une décision critiquée par la
maire de washington qui a décidé
d'annuler toutes les parades habituel
trois cent mille masques sont tout de
même distribué pour l'occasion par le
gouvernement
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue de sur rt france à la
une de l'actualité ce soir cette
première journée pour jean castex comme
premier ministre en france avec des
entretiens dès ce matin à l'elysée pour
former son nouveau gouvernement
puis il s'est rendu vous le voyez en
banlieue parisienne pour visiter une
entreprise de recherche et de production
à corbeil essonnes une manière pour
montrer que la priorité du gouvernement
ce sera la relance de l'économie
et ils l'assurent elle passera par la
sauvegarde de l'emploi par des liens
étroits avec les collectivités locales
et des relocalisations écoutez le
l'objectif du gouvernement l'objectif de
l'état ses devoirs dans le cadre du plan
de relance de reconstruction des
conséquences qu'on va tirer de cette
crise comment ne pas simplement agir son
court terme c'est déjà très important
pour éviter le maximum de licenciement
comment on peut assurer les fondements
d'une relocalisation d'un maintien
durable des emplois industriels est
exposé à la concurrence dans notre pays
jean castex qui a été accueilli dans
l'essonne par la mère du coudray
montceaux aurélie gros qui a été élu dès
le premier tour
le premier ministre qui a été reçu dans
par la mère de france est mère française
et elle a échangé avec lui notamment sur
le rôle des territoires et les
relocalisations et la santé écouter on a
parlé effectivement relocalisation vous
savez il ya eu cette problématique
notamment autour du des masques qui a
été un grands sujets pendants ces
différents mans vous imaginez que les
masques ont tous été achetés presque en
chine
donc c'est le comble aujourd'hui il faut
relocaliser et quand on regarde ce
fleuron de d'entreprise en essonne où
vous avez une entreprise qui est assez
exceptionnel sur les nanotechnologies
qui fabriquent nos puces de téléphone
parce que je le dis aussi pour les
téléspectateurs
c'est important de savoir qu'en france
il ya ses spécificités et aujourd'hui
ces entreprises là sont confrontés sont
confrontés à plusieurs pour les grèves
n'ont pas arrêté pendant le confinement
ils ont continué 7 jours sur 7
ils se sont équipés ils ont essayé de
trouver des solutions ils sont faits des
territoires mais ils sont encore
confrontées à la problématique du
recrutement alors qu'on sait que
beaucoup de français cherche encore de
l'emploi du recrutement
qui souvent est due aussi à la
problématique des transports et ces
sujets là ont été ont été échangés avec
le premier ministre et il a été très à
l'écouté et à promis en tout cas aux
entreprises d'être un soutien et c'était
un signe fort pour eux jean castex qui
l'y a ensuite repris la direction de
l'elysée pour discuter avec emmanuel
macron envie de former son gouvernement
et il veut aller vite d'ici à lundi ce
sera fait at il dit hier dans les médias
il devrait prononcer sa déclaration de
politique générale en milieu de semaine
pierre jan masaryk un dernier tour et
puis s'en va edouard philippe petit
matignon après trois ans de loyaux
services il va retrouver sa ville du
havre où il devrait très certainement
reprendre ses fonctions de maire une
passation durant laquelle visiblement
très ému il a encensé son successeur
jean castex
je vous souhaite très sincèrement
beaucoup de réussite beaucoup de succès
du succès pour vous bien entendu mais
surtout du succès pour notre pays et
notre pays qui a traversé cette crise
sanitaire qui a traversé d'autres crises
a besoin d'un esprit ouvert et d'une
main ferme
mais je pense que vous avez cet esprit
ouvert et cette main ferme une
nomination surprise alors que d'autres
noms comme ceux de florence parly ou
jean yves le drian circulait depuis
plusieurs jours pour reprendre les rênes
du gouvernement
c'est finalement ce républicain proche
de nicolas sarkozy
inconnu du grand public qui a su tirer
son épingle du jeu
sa priorité désormais poursuivre les
réformes
instauré par le précédent gouvernement
la crise économique et sociale elle est
déjà là et il nous faudra plus que
jamais réunir la nation pour lutter
contre cette crise qui s'installe et
surtout dans la continuité des réformes
de fond que vous avez entrepris pour
faire en sorte que nous en sortions plus
fort et plus solidaire jean castex a
désormais la lourde tâche de former un
nouveau gouvernement un remaniement
attendu en début de semaine prochaine
elle voyait à présent l'analyse de jean
garrigues sur le nouveau chef du
gouvernement
il est historien et politologue et
professeur à l'université d'orléans
on sait bien que la tante prioritaires
des français portent sur la relance
économique et le chômage
donc il me paraît assez cohérent de
donner une priorité à ce plan de relance
et c'est très frappant de voir que avant
même que le gouvernement ne soit formé
on a un premier ministre qui est déjà
sur le terrain et qui veut indiquer en
allant à la rencontre de cette
entreprise d'abord une forme de
souveraineté industrielle et puisqu'il
s'agit d'un secteur de pointe pour
l'industrie française
et puis l'urgence de ceux de ce plan de
redressement c'est c'est un signe assez
fort alors que keith et aux français et
sur le plan social une première journée
pour jean castex marquée par des
protestations en france trois
manifestations organisées par les gilet
jaune aujourd'hui à paris peu nombreux
mais toujours aussi déterminée
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter thomas bonnin ils étaient
plusieurs dizaines à manifester dans les
rues de la capitale ce samedi une
manifestation d gilet jaune avec une
faible mobilisation quelques dizaines de
manifestants une cinquantaine peut-être
au plus fort de la mobilisation une
faible participation qui s'explique
notamment par et bien le fait qu'il y
avait trois manifestations autorisées
aujourd'hui parler gilet jaune des
divisions en interne n'ont pas permis
faire un cortège unique et ce qu'est ce
qui explique en partie l'éparpillement
de ces manifestants ce samedi on a
interrogé faouzi lellouche sur justement
cette faible mobilisation je propose de
l'écouter il est normal que ça soit
faible mobilisation vu la répression
qu'il ya eu des tas ils sont servis des
bras armés on va dire des policiers et
beaucoup de gens étaient et de la
justice parce que beaucoup de gens ont
été condamnés
beaucoup de gens étaient aussi blessé et
il est normal que les gens aient peur de
sortir
ça c'est une chose et en même temps il
ya le quotidien je pense que on a fait
ce qui n'est jamais arrivé c'est à dire
un mouvement qui a duré maintenant on
peut dire deux ans mais vraiment actif
pendant un an et demi et je pense qu'on
a tous besoin de vivre on a tous des
obligations et il est normal qu'à un
moment donné on est obligé de revenir à
nos obligations parce que sinon on va se
retrouver nous-mêmes a dénoncé les gens
qui sont sdf les gens dans la précarité
les inégalités on va se retrouver dehors
quoi une manifestation d gilet jaune qui
intervient au lendemain de la nomination
d'un nouveau premier ministre en
l'occurrence monsieur jean castex
l'occasion pour nous d'interroger les
manifestants sur ce qu'il pense de ce
nouvel homme fort du gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron je propose de les
écouter au micro de nicolas va clair je
pense que c'est juste un changement un
changement de marionnettes en fait et et
que ça changera pas grand chose ils
resteront toujours sur leur politique et
on obtiendra toujours pas ce qu'on
voudra c'est encore une plaisanterie ce
mois je pense pas que ça va changer
grand chose étant donné qu'il est choisi
par le pouvoir en place
le gouvernement il est
unis d'un seul bloc contre sa population
je n'hésite pas à le dire finalement la
démocratie aujourd'hui qu'on veut nous
vendre
c'est un simulacre voilà parmi les
manifestants certains estiment qu'il est
peut-être temps de modifier la façon de
manifester la façon de faire entendre
leurs revendications verra donc si
d'autres manifestations des gilet jaune
se tiendront dans les samedis suivants
en tout cas la date du 14 juillet a été
cochée dans les agendas icipe des
participants pour mener différentes
actions et puis tous nous donne déjà
rendez vous pour la rentrée de septembre
une entrée qui s'annonce difficile ce
sont les mots du président de la
république et pour les manifestants le
mois de septembre sera peut-être
synonyme d'une rentrée chargée
d'un point de vue social autres
manifestations en france après la
mobilisation des salariés d'air france
hier celle des salariés de nokia à
lannion en bretagne
aujourd'hui le fabricant de téléphones
mobiles qui veut supprimer 408 postes en
france près de 5000 personnes vous le
voyez ont manifesté en fin de matinée
une mobilisation qui précède une
manifestation à paris le 8 juillet
prochain
l'intersyndicale qui demandent à la
direction purement et simplement de
retirer son plan de licenciement c'est
ce que réclame notamment jean françois
schmitt il est délégué syndical cfe cgc
à l' usine nokia
il a absolument pas justifiée puisque
tous en fête aujourd'hui les chiffres
sont bons les chiffres économiques sont
bons c'était vraiment un effet d'aubaine
à la plus décorée d'un virus pour eux
pour en fait passer ce plan au travers
de badens dans l'ambiance générale des
plans sociaux donc ça permet en fait de
fait de faire discrètement fait des
délocalisations ce que ce que ce que
nokia toujours prêt en fait prévu de
faire en fait depuis le le rachat
d'alcatel-lucent 21,4 en fait
yvon ceux qui veulent se désengager de
la france une journée politique chargé
aujourd'hui en france avec l'élection du
maire de marseille la cité phocéenne qui
a basculé à gauche avec l'élection de
michel rubio la première femme à être
élue
la mairie de la ville elle succède à
jean claude gaudin à l'issue d'un
conseil municipal à rebondissements
une victoire obtenue grâce au soutien de
dernière minute de la candidate
socialiste sam ex socialiste samia ghali
mais michel rubio là qui a recueilli 50
et une voix contre 40 et une pour le
républicain guy teissier un peu plus tôt
dans la journée vous voyez le candidat
du rassemblement national stéphane
ravier s'est retirée du scrutin avec ses
huit élus ils sont partis en dénonçant
je cite des accords de circonstance au
détriment d'un débat pour les
marseillais edouard philippe lui sera
élu maire du havre demain matin l'ancien
locataire de matignon qui ne quitte pas
tout à fait paris puisqu'il aurait été
chargé par emmanuel macron de rebâtir la
majorité en vue de l'élection
présidentielle l'ancien premier ministre
qui est également sous le coup d'une
enquête judiciaire de la cour de justice
de la république
neuf plaintes ont été jugés recevables
contre lui et les ministres de la santé
les anciens ministres de la santé
olivier veron et année ce besoin pour la
gestion de la crise sanitaire dans un
communiqué edouard philippe s'est dit
prêt à apporter toutes les réponses
nécessaires à lenquête depuis le début
de cette épidémie 90 plaintes ont été
enregistrées contre edward physique ou
l'un de ses anciens ministres
une fête nationale de l'indépendance à
haut risque sanitaire aux états unis
pour donald trump qui doit s'exprimer ce
soir à washington la nuit dernière le
président américain s'est rendu au mont
rushmore c'est ce lieu où il y à vous le
voyez cette célèbre sculpture des
présidents washington jefferson et
roosevelt et lincoln un déplacement en
terrain conquis pour lui dans le dakota
du sud fief des républicains malgré
quelques manifestants vous le voyez au
mont rushmore donald trump s'en est
prise aux sites au foule furieuse qui
veulent détruire l'amérique écouter
[Musique]
notre nation assiste à une campagne
impitoyable visant à effacer notre
histoire a diffamé nos héros à effacer
nos valeurs et endoctrinée nos enfants
des soul en colère et c'est de démolir
les statuts de nos fondateurs de
défigurer nos monuments les plus sacrés
de déclencher une vague de crimes
violents dans nos villes les cérémonies
de la fête nationale américaine sont
maintenus par la maison blanche mais
annulée par la maire de washington
la crise sanitaire et le port du masque
sont devenus vous allez le voir un
véritable enjeu politique grégoire
doucet c'est dans un contexte sanitaire
toujours plus critique que prennent
place les célébrations de la fête de
l'indépendance américaine
après le mont rushmore donald trump
résidera les parade de la fête nationale
depuis la capitale et ce malgré les
récents appels à la prudence de la mer
de washington nous donnons aux habitants
de washington le même message sur toutes
leurs sorties du week end férié
demandez vous si vous avez besoin d'être
là demandez vous si vous pouvez
anticiper ou savoir qui sera autour de
vous si vous allez en ville
savez vous si vous allez pouvoir
respecter la distanciation sociale savez
vous si vous allez monter dans une rame
de métro bondée
savez vous si les personnes qui sont
assises à côté de vous et qui présentent
des symptômes sont malades ou portent
des masques
moquée pour le sobriquet de guerrier
solitaire qu'il s'est auto-attribué le
président américain cristallise
également les critiques autour du port
du masque si la maison blanche prévoit
d'en distribuer 300 milles pour la foule
qui souhaitent assister aux parades
lui-même n'apparaît jamais masqué en
public en recul dans les sondages à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
le milliardaire préfère capitaliser sur
ses résultats économiques plutôt que sur
les thématiques sanitaires actuelles et
vante régulièrement son bilan sur
l'emploi
j'aimerais annoncer une nouvelle
spectaculaire pour les travailleurs et
des familles américaines et pour notre
pays tout entier il n'y a jamais rien
de tels c'est un record il vient d'être
annoncé que l'économie américaine a créé
près de cinq millions d'emplois au mois
de juin
déjouant ainsi tous tes attentes c'est
donc un 4 juillet à la saveur bien
particulière pour les américains très
divisée depuis plusieurs semaines par
des questions sociétales et sanitaires
et on en parle ce soir avec françois
durpaire spécialiste des états unis
bonsoir françois durpaire merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france donald trump
devrait prendre la parole ce soir est ce
que c'est un second essai en tout cas
après le flop de son premier meeting on
s'en souvient en oklahoma est ce que
donald trump va essayer de récupérer des
points ce soir
oui c'est important pour lui parce que
vous avez dit ce premier meeting a été
difficile
il ya un enjeu c'est l'inscription sur
les listes électorales vous savez qu
avant de voter il faut s'inscrire est là
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
les républicains sont en retard dans le
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
dans un certain nombre d'états et puis
il y a le différentiel dans les sons
base qui devient très important - 10 et
dans quatre états déterminant la flore
et de michigan la pennsylvanie et louise
consignes et bien donald trump est battu
par son adversaire joe biden qui lui ne
fait pas grand chose ce soir lui il sera
en train de répondre à des questions sur
la question raciale
une journaliste afro américaine
d'événements qui est donc organisée ou
dix fois qu'il va du côté de cet
électorat afro américain joe biden
tandis que donne un train pluie et c'est
de creuser les divisions de l'amérique
c'est sa stratégie vous l'avais dit dans
le reportage
le discours notamment un homo rushmore
hier était particulièrement édifiant
moyens un discours où il critiquait
notamment le fait qu'on s'en prennent
aux symboles de l'amérique
7 ces manifestations du mouvement black
l'armateur saluer à créer du temps à
donald trump
oui alors ce qui a créé du tort à denain
craintes et ses deux choses c'est
effectivement d'une part le kobe 19
cette crise sanitaire on lui reproche
aujourd'hui vous savez il disait c'est
le virus des chinois est aujourd'hui les
américains beaucoup en tout cas dit
c'est le virus de donald trump
évidemment c'est pas lui qui a créé le
virus mais il lui reproche deux choses
la première c'est l'insuffisance sur le
plan technique il a pris des décisions
trop tardivement et peut-être pas les
bonnes et la deuxième c'est
l'insuffisance en matière j'allais dire
presque d'humanisme un chef d'état ce
n'est pas un chef de gouvernement
on attend de lui également des mots pour
soigner la société pour accompagner les
malades les malades et leurs familles
des mots de compassion et demande que
george deubeuliou bush lors de trina en
2005 avait décroché dans les sondages au
moment de la catastrophe de katrina et
bien donald trump lui décroche dans les
sondages à ce moment là
sauf que la différence est que george
deubeuliou bush il avait pas besoin
d'être réélu c'était son deuxième mandat
de d'un train pluie a besoin d'être
réélu alors il ya aussi cette guerre des
masques qui devient politique puisque
selon un sondage les républicains en
porto - alors que les démocrates sont
plutôt partisan de les porter c'est
devenu un symbole quasiment de cette
campagne
ça devrait un simple outil sanitaires et
c'est devenu comme vous l'avez dit un
outil politique vous portez un masque et
bien ça veut dire que vous êtes
démocrate vous n'en portait pas ça veut
dire que vous souhaitez le président
d'ailleurs ce fameux discours hier au
mont rushmore il y avait kim ben ali
qu'il fouille de qui est la petite amie
la compagne du chis cédé 2,2 d'un train
qui est bien n'avait pas de masse mais
vous savez que l es malade à elle et à
la locaux vides 19 comme un autre
responsable de la campagne de denain
train personnes quasiment de porter de
masque lors de ce discours
nouvelle provocation du camp donald
trump à ces démocrates qui eux dit
il y a vraiment une question de
satisfaire vous savez quel gars aux
envies 20000 contaminé de plus par jour
aux états unis
c'est pour vous donner une appréciation
à peu près cinq fois plus que dans
l'union européenne qui pourtant contre
440 millions d'habitants c'est à dire un
tiers de plus que la population
américaine et du côté américain bien on
se dit là il ya vraiment une manière de
sous-estimer les choses si 2 1,30 se
félicite de ces bons résultats
économiques et bien ils devraient se
dire que ces bons résultats ne vont pas
durer très longtemps
ils sont en tout cas dépendant de
l'amélioration durable des résultats
sanitaire ne peut pas y avoir de
résultat économique durable sans une
stabilisation de la situation sanitaire
aux états unis comme d'ailleurs c'est le
cas en europe
il l'a dit on l'a entendu 5 millions
d'emplois créés en juin c'est historique
dit-il sur les contaminations elles sont
effectivement extrêmement nombreux zonal
trendy finalement c'est parce qu'on
teste qu'on découvre qu'il ya des
malades finalement c'est parce que les
tests sont là et qu'on multiplie les les
tests qu'en pensez vous que c'est une
logique arithmétique implacable mais
qu'en fait de le dire de cette manière
là sur beaucoup d'américains parce que
il a l'air de prendre à la légère ce qui
se passe même si sur le chou c'est juste
si vous testez plus eh bien vous avez
plus évidemment de chances de voir des
malades mais le dit d'une manière assez
particulière quand vous l'entendez vous
avez l'impression que et bien ils
sous-estiment la situation
ce qui est inquiétant pour lui c'est que
à moins 10 et derrière joe biden ça veut
dire que seul un seul président avait
réussi à rattraper ce retard c'étaient
truman en juillet 1948 alors vous allez
me dire est-ce que donald trump a déjà
perdu
pas forcément mais pour vous donner
quand même une indication hillary
clinton et bt à +41 et pas plus 10 par
rapport à donald trump donc certes
hillary clinton a perdu mais joe biden a
quand même des avantages par rapport à
hillary clinton lorsqu'on garde deux
choses la première c'est le vote des
indépendants quand on regarde ces
fameuses indépendants et bien
joe biden est beaucoup moins polarisant
qu'hillary clinton ya beaucoup plus de
gens qui l'aiment et beaucoup moins de
gens qui le détestent
et puis il ya un deuxième chose c'est le
fameux vote des plus jeunes qui se
mobilisaient vous aviez cité blacklight
matin qui se sont mobilisés qui se sont
mobilisés aussi pour bernie sanders ne
s'était pas reporter sur hillary clinton
mais là d'après toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion il semble que ce vote étudiant
ce vote des jeunes américains et bien se
reportent vers joe biden pour une raison
simple c'est que la stratégie de
polarisation le discours la rhétorique
belliciste de donald rentes stimule son
électorat mais stimule également ses
opposants et en particulier les jeunes
vous parlez d'une rhétorique belliciste
on va finir là-dessus donald trump s'est
qualifié lui-même de guerrier solitaire
ça a fait rire aussi aux états unis oui
alors évidemment ça fait rire le camp
qui n'aiment pas de dalle trans ça
stimule ses troupes
mais la question c'est effectivement un
la mobilisation en particulier la
mobilisation de ces fameux de ces fameux
électeurs plus jeunes et puis évidemment
ces indépendants les démocrates savent
qu'ils voteront contre denain trimpe les
républicains tour mais ce sont les
indépendants dans quelques états clés
qui vont faire la différence et si le
vote à des lieux aujourd'hui deux
d'entre eux seraient balayés par joe
biden le vote n'a pas lieu aujourd'hui
la lieu dans quatre mois ça nous laisse
encore le temps de d'analyser cette
situation et ça donne encore un peu de
temps la seule bonne nouvelle pour donne
un train c'est qu'il reste encore quatre
mois et on en reparlera avec plaisir
avec vous françois durpaire merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur arte france
et on finit avec cette situation
inquiétante au venezuela notamment pour
l'activité pétrolière qui est lourdement
touchée les plateformes sont
complètement paralysée faute de pouvoir
écouler le pétrole brut
principale source de ce problème les
sanctions américaines et l'effondrement
du secteur
aucune plateforme d'extraction on était
en activité au mois de juin une
situation dramatique pour ce pays qu'il
traverse une importante crise économique
oui ce qu'on dit philippe chalmin
économiste et spécialiste des matières
premières que l'embargo américain
contribue à la totale paralysie de
l'économie pétrolière vénézuélienne
elle s'y était déjà terriblement touchée
par toutes l'anarchie politiques liées
au gouvernement madonna justin chiffres
dans les années 60 lorsque le pen a été
créé il y avait trois grands producteurs
mondiaux de pétrole qui ont été des
membres fondateurs de l'opep s'étaient
l'iran l'arabie saoudite et le venezuela
et chacun produisent et aux alentours de
4 millions de barils par jour au mois de
juin
le venezuela a probablement produite
moins de 400 mille barils jour et ce
pétrole comme vous l'avez dit du fait
des sanctions américaines à l'encontre
du gouvernement maduro ce pétrole il ne
parvient pas à l'exporter dans la mesure
où il ya très peu de compagnies
pétrolières il ya très peu de compagnies
maritimes qui veulent prendre le risque
de travailler avec du pétrole
vénézuélien
et puis au royaume uni une quarantaine
d'organisations de défense des droits
humains ont demandé au gouvernement
britannique la libération immédiate de
julian assange les signataires qui
appellent à bloquer l'extradition du
fondateur de wikileaks vers les états
unis
il risque jusqu'à 175 ans de prison il
est détenu à londres cet australien qui
est accusé d'avoir mis en danger des
sources des services américains les ong
estiment je cite que la persécution à la
persécution oui de julian assange
contribuer à une détérioration de la
liberté de la presse au au royaume uni
fin de citation voyez ce qu'on dit
anthony bellanger il est secrétaire
général de la fédération internationale
des journalistes
ça vole il est on est en train de nommer
quelqu'un de dénoncer quelqu'un qui a un
qui n'a fait que son travail et il est
devenu aujourd'hui l'ennemi public
numéro un de l'administration américaine
puisqu'il a il ya il a mis au jour des
informations d'intérêt public et qui ont
été justifiées par par le travail de
wikileaks depuis le depuis tant d'années
dire d'un côté le 8 juin dernier que les
gens doivent pouvoir faire leur travail
et de l'autre continuer à maintenir en
détention à un homme qui n'a fait que
son travail a dénoncé des faits de
guerre des crimes de guerre la gagne il
ya un gap il ya une guerre il ya un
fossé qui est tellement énorme que au
nom de la fédération internationale où
et quand même très inquiet et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
restez avec nous on se retrouve dans 30
minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fait que nous avons eu ce prix